[Music]
it was almost
one year ago that raimi inocencio
brought us the very first news
of the coronavirus the number of
infected
exploded over the weekend the airport
here in wuhan has also
started to do body temperature checks of
people before they take flight
not only that when we landed here in
wuhan earlier today
we saw people many of them wearing masks
taking a look at what's happening in the
united states u.s officials
want to make sure that they are raising
the defenses and that is what they are
doing there
because right now as of now there has
not been a u.s infection as of yet
well since that report the virus has
killed more than 397 thousand americans
and that number is projected to reach
500 000 half a million next month in the
latest cbs news poll
most americans think vaccine
distribution is moving too slowly at
this time
and president-elect biden promises 100
million vaccine doses
will be given to americans in his first
100 days in office
cbs news medical contributor dr david
agus joins us now dr agus good morning
to you
let's start with that promise from the
incoming biden administration
a hundred million shots in a hundred
days is that realistic
thank you good morning tony yeah it's a
bold promise but i think an important
one and a doable one
in order for that to happen we need the
astrazeneca and the johnson johnson
vaccine to receive regulatory approval
because there are large stocks of them
available now and we need to step up
what we're doing across the country
to get vaccines from freezers into
people's arms i don't
fully understand dr agus and maybe you
can shed some light on it why
if 31 or so million doses have been
distributed
only 12 million or so have been actually
put into people's arms
why the gap well
every state was given the right to make
their own criteria for who to vaccinate
and how to vaccinate
and many of them are having difficulty
with it they're having difficulty with
the software pre-registering people so
that can go smoothly they're having
difficulty following people for 15 to 30
minutes
afterwards which you have to with the
two rna vaccines
and you know i think when they also get
very you know targeted in who they're
going to vaccinate
it's much more difficult some states
that have had broad
criteria everybody over the age of 65
etc
have had much better luck getting
vaccines into people's arms
i think we're going to need a
federalization so the federal government
should be in charge of distribution
and who gets the vaccines and how to do
it and i think it will run
much much easier yeah it's a costly
lesson to learn this late in the
in the pandemic so if the federal
government takes a stronger approach to
distributing and actually vaccinating
people what's your rough estimate for
when the general population
will be able to receive a vaccine
well when you start to look at this if
we get these four vaccines onto the
market remember that the second two j
and astrazeneca there's no 15 to 30
minute waiting time it's not frozen
very easy to distribute to doctor's
offices not just to the big centers in
the city
but to doctors offices across the
country which will make things happen
much more efficiently
so i really believe we can do this by
the summer and that we can get
75 to 85 percent of americans vaccinated
will
bring us hurt immunity and then several
months later we will see a fall in the
virus and getting back to
a more normal way of life yeah we could
all use that
we've seen in five weeks a leap in the
death toll from 300 000 to 400
000. now there are estimates that it
could be at 500
000 by mid-february do you think that's
a realistic
outcome at this point
unfortunately yes i mean we saw recently
the peak from
christmas and new year's where people
got together and we saw an increased
number of viruses
lagged later by an increased number of
deaths it's leveled off now
slightly declining but i think we're
going to see a significant increase over
the next several weeks from the mutant
strains these are strains that are much
more contagious
than the classic or the cova 19 we have
been fighting for the last 11 months or
12 months
and so these are much easier to spread
we're going to see an increase in those
cases
and unfortunately increasing the death
rate which will lag the increase in
cases happening next month
uh all right dr agus thank you very much
i appreciate it very illuminating